got me all hyped about a secret topic
all right here let's go
podcast 137 also
oh yeah
yeah
nico's got a secret topic he's gonna ask
me about i don't know what it's about
all right sick oh gorgeous dude sounding
good man this is a nice sounding guitar
hey thanks it's a
it's a yeah it's offender
[Laughter]
i was gonna i was gonna buy a martin and
then you were like look
jake you've been playing guitar since
you were 12. it's okay you can buy a
martin
and i was like yeah but i don't think i
play enough you know and then
and i almost did but then i found this
all black fender at a local music store
and i bought i bought it there's
something about that local music store
that just gives things a magical sound
and a magical price
exactly yeah
so today's topic jake is adobe versus
resolve slash blackmagic vs
foundry and nuke
the war is on so the war is
on
so
and adobe is losing we've had a lot of
issues with adobe products in the
studios is particularly premier uh just
being
like literally fresh installed on a
fresh computer and just does not work
right off the bat the part is like is
this program broken like
what is going on
matt lost a whole day of work uh just
last week because uh
the like there wasn't anything
particular that he was doing he was just
assembling footage
and the file just corrupted and like he
had to like redo the entire project file
yeah it's the worst
this stuff happens totally random so
there's no explanation for it so so ren
made a tweet today jake and we're going
to read through this tweet thread here
uh we'll give you a little yeah okay let
me let me pull it up
yeah
um here i'll play ren
okay
after effects needs to be rewritten from
the ground up or i'm not using this
[ __ ] program anymore
it's one of those kind of tweets
i kind of have to agree with him but
honestly it's really premier that needs
that i mean on
both of them let's be real yeah yeah
after effects at least kind of works
half the time and so then adobe responds
who wants to be adobe
uh hey ren um we're here if you need us
we can bring specific issues to devs
offer troubleshooting suggestions or you
know put you in direct contact with
someone on the team happy to help
let us know what's going on with your
app caroline should i be should i be
freddie yeah
oh freddie replied oh god you're trying
but social media alone cannot pay the
accumulation of decades of technical
debt lol
[Laughter]
um
with interest
and then
oh this is back to you caroline oh did
she respond to freddie looks like it oh
nice uh doing what i can lol oh she
lulled uh these threads really do get
sent up the ladder and help us move
mountains every little bit helps
caroline
oh our next comment sweet hey caleb you
can send this podcast to the executives
also
you guys are going hard in the paint
today i love it let's go
all right
oh man
dude all right so adobe i don't know if
you're listening but
boy
davinci resolve is so stable it's so
it's so smooth and it uses all of my gpu
when i fire out my net like my
performance meters and i see my gpu at
100 percent it makes me feel like it was
worth it when we put our blood sweat and
tears into making these machines you
know it's just like it's nice and we
oh man i i installed premiere 20 you
know what i just realized nico's not
even sitting upright
at this point
he's like
better and jordan are your therapists
yeah and you are on the therapy couch
right now
you know when you wear a sling one of
the best feelings in the day is when you
get to like stretch your shoulders out
backwards just a little bit
and like i am i'm living life right now
because i'm lying down feels great i can
work
from a horizontal position today thanks
to this podcast
good good that's great but yeah you were
saying so i was i was just gonna i was
running a little like
color space test i just needed to import
like a prores file
and like change change of value like it
was the most basic of things i'm like
well i might as well install premiere
2022 the most recent version right you
know instead of keeping i was using 20
20. oh uh so i did and i installed it i
always keep the old versions just in
case
and i turn i open it up and i drag in
the you know.mov prorose file and then i
put in my timeline and then just doesn't
load
it's like really a fresh install of 2022
the most recent update version all i did
is i just dragged a prores file the most
basic of operations into the dang
timeline and then just it won't render
in the window and it's like
really
really
why can't it render it why can't it
render in the window why can't it render
in the in the viewer and it's like
oh my gosh like these are it's like
opening word and then just like the
letters aren't there
you hit you hit r and it gives you f and
you're just like no i don't know
no i don't want this yeah it's like well
what can they do to help it's like
i don't need to fix this for you like
we're paying 50 a month times what like
times 10 or something like that just to
get all these like licenses well well
okay let me just sorry so
i'm chilling out i'm bringing it back
there's a couple reasons i'd love to go
into theories about why this is perhaps
we could bring on like
the ceo of adobe
bring on caroline
uh
ceo has been ceo since 2007. oh well it
is
um
it's a man named shantanu
he's an indian american business
executive and he's 58 years old
now if we can bring on mr narian we can
we can get into the actuals of why this
is
um so you know there's that opportunity
but i'd love to i'd love to hear it from
from all you guys
in your experience what this has been
like as well
but my my thought is is because look at
their stock price
oh i'm intrigued
yeah it's it just keeps i mean it's come
down a ton but
it just keeps doing it
it just it okay it went up
from like
it's gone down in the last year since
the pandemic has come to an come to a
close right but
from from 2011
to like even before that
all the way up to 2021 it just kept
going higher no like there was it went
from like 28
in 2011 to this december 2011 to
december 2021
being
650 well they really pioneered the whole
like subscription service like
professional software thing
except it's just they haven't backed it
up with the professional software side
when it comes to like
adobe premiere in my opinion and to an
extent now after effects like
there's some things that are cool but
it's like professional to me means i can
rely on it for my business
and when you lose a day of work because
the program just on its own not because
you're doing anything special just on
its own it shits the bed and there's not
even like a thing in there to deal with
it [ __ ] the bed means like what are
you doing with our money like you know
it's like i'm okay paying subscription
prices for professional software
but like
and i feel like they're in a state now
because it's subscription they're
constantly trying to do updates and
they're constantly trying to show new
things because those bring in new
subscriptions but they're just putting
more floors on like this creaky
like
patchwork
it's like a turn of the century
farmhouse and they're trying to do like
uh
mcmansion out of it yeah it's like
creating a windmill to like get
electricity at the top it's like wow
it's really shiny and cool and
futuristic but the base is you know his
old farmhouse
yeah
why do they have 26 000 employees
oh my gosh
why do they need 26 000 employees
i don't know man that's a lot of people
i mean they have a lot of players they
have like you know 60 or 50 programs or
something like that and they've absorbed
a lot of others like yeah
all the substance painter yeah stuff
like that they took on and
mixamo i have to say thank you for that
that's making those great fantastic
adobe correct
yeah
they do own miximo yeah that's nice yeah
maximo is wonderful but yeah it's just
like those main programs and you know
when you're troubleshooting
and you are troubleshooting for hours on
end and it's nothing to do with you that
is the most infuriating feeling in the
world i find peace in my heart if it's
my fault i felt so bad for ren today
yeah like we've all been there and it
was just like
everything you're doing is causing the
program to crash
and it should be like he was doing i
believe he was saying it was just a roto
mask yeah just a simple very very simple
mask now yeah and that was enough for it
to go nah yeah
i feel like
a roto mask in after effects
and it was just yeah exploding
like the the the if if i'm a baby
and i want to do a roto mask you're
going to tell me to do it in a in after
effects yes yeah that's like that's
whenever he starts the first row of
masks
do you actually traumatizing that baby
would be how traumatized that baby would
be when the rotomass doesn't work in the
very first time they're like they'll
question their reality they don't know
what to think
hey guys jake watson here and normally i
do these brand integrations for you all
but today i've got to tell you about
something that's really been
life-changing for me okay you see i was
once a humble video creator maybe much
like yourself sitting in front of my
computer trying to find a way to cut my
video scenes together and i realized
that i had shot no connective tissue
whatsoever to tie one scene to another i
started to panic i had a mental
breakdown i lost my job i became
homeless for a little while and then i
then i really did some soul searching
and i realized that was because i didn't
have a stock asset resource for all my
stock asset needs but courtesy of
today's sponsor story blocks life's so
much better now things are really
looking up because you know what i don't
have to go out and soul search and do
the incredibly laborious and
time-consuming work of trying to shoot
my own b-roll or collect my own stock
images for the connective tissue in my
videos so you see the thing about
storyblocks is they have a virtually
unlimited library of high quality 4k
b-roll images audio assets and more and
you can get it all royalty-free with
their unlimited all-access plan it's
what we use here at corridor digital all
the time since discovering this but
seriously guys if you are serious about
creating you're going to need a stock
asset tool and the best one that we've
found is story blocks so that's why it's
such an easy integration here it's easy
for me to tell you hey we use them all
the time we use them every day honestly
it's a phenomenal tool they're a great
team and it's a wonderful resource for
creators so if you guys are interested
in getting started for yourself head on
over to storyblocks.com or just click
the link in the description of this
video or go to storyblocks.com
corridorcast
and again huge thank you to them for
always sponsoring this podcast and
always being a part of the chord or
digital creative journey head on over to
storybox.com quartercast and now back to
the podcast
there's a plugin that just dropped for
after effects called workflower and it
does so many things that should be built
into the program that are sitting there
explicitly requested by people for years
and just once again it's like what are
you guys doing what are you waiting for
who is calling the shots yeah and what's
going into this program like and why are
they calling these shots like it has
basic things like hey
putting a filter to multiple layers at
the same time and controlling it from
one filter it has things like you know
specific specified adjustment layers
like photoshop so you can be like all
right this adjustment layer is going to
feed out to these three layers and only
affect those three layers yeah these are
like basic
necessary things that after effects has
needed for over a decade
more than that it's needed since it's
been invented you know
and just
yeah it's it really frustrates me but
you know what at the end of the day
we've started looking for alternatives
and that's just the reality like we
haven't gotten hard in advertising that
we like we are moving away from adobe
and like we still pay for a bunch of
licenses because we need to have these
licenses because people still use
premiere in after effects but
we've made a really heavy shift to
davinci resolve for all of our editing
and you know fenner's coming in here and
he's preaching about nuke but i've been
poking around in fusion also and
just you start to see some things you
know in this other it's like it's like
being in north korea and then you get
out of north korea and
you start to see some of these other
things that exist adobe is north korea
look i'm being very hyperbolic
how did this
happen what what
what is this well it's a node but yeah
it's very true because you don't know
what you're missing until you're out of
there yeah and the minute that you leave
north korea you realize like oh shoot no
there's some incredible tools yeah that
makes so much sense just logically when
you're trying to composite like fenner
showed me a bunch of stuff and i go oh
my gosh like this is this would be the
greatest plug-in in after effects
history oh no this would be the greatest
play and there's just so many of those
that you go
why isn't this
why isn't this working on that same
level yeah and you just have to assume
it's priority at this point like the
priority is new subscribers
maybe below prosumer level you know you
kind of have to just assume that's what
they're focused on yeah and you know if
if you're just like hey i
what what program to edit my videos you
know and you're like beginner beginner
creator
and you you capture a couple mp4s
and you throw them in your timeline and
you're like oh okay i cut it together
look that was better than the free
software on my
computer
that came with the computer or whatever
um
and maybe that's all they're going after
i don't i don't know
um
looking at their their numbers again
their financials their their gross
profit in 2018 was 7.8
million
uh 2019 9.5 million 2020 11.1 2021 13.9
so they've they've
but for a company that has
26 000 employees with a market cap of
200 billion
to only be profiting that much seems
like what are they spending their money
on i don't know but yeah it seems it
seems like that's more what they're
interested in than just like
than their actual like
professional use of their tool it
doesn't feel like they exist to try to
make the best software right now it
feels like they exist
to get the most subscribers and software
is the tool the ends to their goal
and you know i get it you know you need
resources and money to make your stuff
but you know i wish i wish companies out
there that were stood for like these
things like adobe stands for creative
software like i wish that was truly
their priority and the flow of their
money demonstrated that you know things
are like hey we're gonna we're gonna
reapproach premiere and rebuild it so
it's stable and has a modernized plug-in
infrastructure it has basic things it
has like an aces workflow for color you
know things like that where it's just
like let's reestablish this and let's
make it work
and i know it's not gonna be cool
because we're not gonna have any new
features for two years but
you know i think adobe's wrong that they
that they don't think that this is not
going to cost the money or that it isn't
costing them money like if adobe turned
around and went hey guys we spent two or
three years or however many years it
takes
building these pieces of software now
from the ground up they're modernized
they're stable the uis are clean like we
redid it like i would jump back in in a
heartbeat like great awesome take my
money let's go you know yeah with that
many employees you feel like that should
be doable as well like imagine how
awesome it would be if because i like i
learned all
like started all my vfx stuff using
photoshop after effects premiere yeah
like and it's imagine if that was like
we could live in that adobe ecosystem
for all of our work like
and it worked like because it would be
so nice like but now it's like i don't
know man you go and use like davinci and
it's just like oh it just works and it's
like so much better yeah and that that
you know the the aces thing for for me
was the first time that i
really kind of realized the issues like
for the first because because me and
nico we were playing around with with
aces for uh to the death
um and that's the lightsaber video yeah
the lightsaber video and
you know it's it's quite a convoluted
setup and it's funny because every
renderer now respects aces and a lot of
them default to it like i know redshift
defaults to aces and of course you know
nuke has a very very competent and quick
way of working in aces and all the color
works and makes sense and i even tried
just recently to go back and run
something through after effects through
the asus pipeline and the color just
wasn't right with my render it just
wasn't understanding what i wanted and
it very frustrating because it should be
just up and running like everyone else
is yeah everyone else has has carried
the baton that much further and it's
almost like coasting on name recognition
i almost think of a parallel to bioware
i don't know if you guys know that oh
the game company bioware where it was
like they were the gem they were like
yeah oh they made the best stuff and
they just they like i think they got
acquired but you know they lost focus
over time and then it was more about the
money than the game yeah there you go
yeah yeah so sorry i misquoted the the
revenue it's not millions it's billions
but oh oh no
but i switcheroo but it still follows
your point jordan yeah yeah yeah so i
mean that's my thing is you know the the
focus
i mean with yeah yeah with ea there you
go is on prioritizing how much you can
bring in and way less on the art or yeah
in this case the software and it tells
but now it's getting to a point where
us who have been loyalists or at least i
know you know nico's been a loyalist
i've been a super loyalist since i
started are now fed up enough to leave
yeah and i feel like that's indicative
of
what's the sentiment getting rent to
swear
how dare you it's like it's not the
first time it's crashed on him it's not
the tenth time it's crash on him yeah
it's not the 100th time it's crashed on
him yeah it's like we're talking like
thousands of times
and it's like i'm done i get that
feeling you know it's just like really
yeah this is what happened with final
cut like 12 years ago yeah yeah it used
to be the final cut used to be the [ __ ]
yeah it did it did final cut 7.
it's funny because you know when when a
program crashes typically i'm like oh
did i do something you know when houdini
crashes typically i've i've been
overbearing if i just give it time it'll
sort itself out but if i'm too
aggressive i'll crash it i just as soon
as it crashes in after effects or in
premiere i know it's not me i'm
immediately guilt-free because i'm so
used to it now i'm just like well it's
not my fault i just gotta try again i'm
gonna do the exact same thing
adobe alibi yeah legit legit so yeah man
i i feel the same way it's sad you know
for those of you listening to this right
now who are in the the video editing and
filmmaking business like
the things to me
that i've been surprised to discover
that i really like when i've moved away
from premiere and into like resolve for
example is having a full-on color
grading like tool set that's built in
parallel to my editing tool set and they
are both like tailored to be the best
that they can be at what they are it's
like in premiere you have lumetri which
is a great plugin but it's a plugin and
so it operates out of a little side
scrolling window and then you have your
viewer and the ui is basically the same
ui that you're using for editing and
like sure you can like shift your
windows around a little bit but at the
end of the day it's like a one size fits
all ui
whereas in davinci resolve i can be
editing and i flip over to color grading
it's a completely different ui that's
focused on color grading
and so really you get two full-blown
tools that are built for the normal
process of your edit because you have to
color at some point if you want to look
good and of course you have to edit it
at some point if you want to have
anything that even comes out of your
computer at some point you know so it's
like
it acknowledges that these two
tools need to coexist side by side and
they need to be what the best that they
can be in and of themselves
and just like that shift of thinking was
like wow it's it's not janky it's like i
get something that's just really nice
and like another thing that's really
stood out to me is just
you know we spend
money on building nice computers you get
a bunch of cpu power you get a bunch of
ram and these days we go and we drop a
bunch of money on gpus
and
a lot of adobe products you know
premiere and after effects once again
they talk about how their gpu
accelerated but they really never
scratch the surface of what your gpu can
do like more often than not my gpu
sitting there like 20 30
because so much of the rest of the code
is all old janky single threaded code
and it just it chokes up on your
computer it doesn't matter how fast or
how many processors you got just matters
how fast that one processor is you know
that one single thread because it's just
there's so much old script that's just
like running and then to like jump over
once again to davinci resolve and you're
working your edit and you see that this
computer like all the money that you
spend on these parts is not going to
waste and your life itself is being
preserved because you have more time and
it's run smoother and you get to see
higher frame rates and you get to watch
it higher resolution and like
the beauty of the work that you're doing
starts to show it's like
you know you sit there and you work in
premiere and you're working with like
your little proxy files and it's all
flat and it looks shitty because it's
not color graded yet you're like oh my
film looks like crap and you just sit in
the state of negativity until you
finally get to finish it and color it
you're like oh actually turns out i was
all right
whereas in davinci resolve from day one
you're like oh this is beautiful my
film's looking good i can make it look
even better and like when we did we
needed to the death like the lightsaber
thing
we did all the lightsaber effects in
davinci resolve in the fusion pages and
everything has you know there's the
correct aces workflow and the linear
light workflow so as we apply like these
glows and these lens flares and these
streaks like they just come to life in
this vibrant
realistic way and you're like oh my my
my movie it looks good
yeah it inspires you and like that's
such a shift and like
these aren't like you know software
points you know you can't fix this like
with a little like update like this is
just i would approach the philosophy
behind the programs and you feel it as
an artist working in them yeah and
you're able to stay in that creative
like flow state because it's not
constantly crashing on you and you have
to restart and then you're like i lost a
day of work oh geez
like matt losing a date that's insane
like and like you're saying it's a
professional product like it's not
that's like it's not discountable yeah
you're paying full whack for it yeah
yeah that's interesting and and uh you
know he's got his finger on the control
s
like yeah yeah because everybody does
yeah so it's not like he lost a day of
work because he didn't hit save
you know it's like no safe file becoming
corrupt it's crazy right i don't i don't
i don't have to save anymore guys i
don't have that drama anymore because
then you resolve
saves every single move you do
in real time so there is no saving
anymore oh it's beautiful oh and it's
also it's stored in a server database so
it's a much more solid harder to corrupt
file format that you can share with
other people at the same time you can
have multiple people working in the same
davinci resolve file so somebody could
be like organizing clips somebody could
be color grading and somebody can be
editing so we can be editing a different
sequence all at the same time in the
same file
and it works
it doesn't crash
i mean look twitchy resolve has crashed
on me before all right
it's crashed a few times just not
thousands of times yeah and every time
it crashes i boot it up and then i
literally resume from the very last
click i just did yeah
it's like yeah whatever
are there are there uh crash files with
uh premiere
i'm trying to remember because i've
never like in working in houdini it's
crashed a couple times and literally
almost every single time was my fault
and i admit that on camera here and how
is it your fault as in like like i'll
over burden it right houdini's does a
very good job of handling a ton of
complex information it just needs time
to do the math but i'm over there
tapping it on the shoulder going
what's it looking like what's it looking
like i was like stop dude and then it'll
crash and say no i'm not doing this
anymore i have to apologize and open it
up again
but uh every single time it gives me a
crash file that works flawlessly i mean
it happened on the vfx iron artist
you know my entire scene crashed because
i was pestering it and it immediately
opened up and it was back from the last
click like nico saying wow and uh i
don't remember ever having that in my
life until now
and i'm wondering maybe it's a feature
that i missed i could just be ignorant
to it but i don't remember remember that
because if it's a feature that you
missed in like other products like adobe
isn't that a sign that it's a flawed
product like not well integrated at all
yeah that's valid like
robust saving should be the number one
the biggest priority more important than
literally anything else in your program
if you're making professional software
like and you shouldn't have to think
about i don't need to check the [ __ ]
autosave box like that should be checked
before you install the goddang program
with your cash files man what are we
going to do wait but do you want to auto
save it yeah you want to auto save it
god damn it
oh oh this feels good it's good to be
okay so if they have 26 000 employees
and they've got
15 billion dollars of annual revenue why
don't they
take that and so it's like we got the
farmhouse right and now the far the farm
has literally thousands of acres
and all you're saying is like hey you
know what
let's just take a few of these people
who are working on the uh electric uh
windmill and uh we'll just bring them
over here and we're just we're just
going to build a new house let's pour it
out yeah strong a nice strong foundation
a modern farmhouse yeah modern
foundation for modern tools modern code
yeah yeah they're gonna bury the pipes
below the frost line and uh it's gonna
happen it's gonna have a nice atrium
when you walk in
air conditioning you can't get them
yeah
yeah not gonna have an outhouse that was
converted into an extension of the
original farmhouse
new bathroom
[Music]
oh my god it was like you know the uncle
rolled up with a really cool trailer
like two years ago and they're like oh
that's really neat um and they just like
nailed it to the side of the house
get those guys in here get your uncle
and his crazy friends in here those guys
uh those guys are doing good bring in
uncle substance come on
it's not yeah it's not a good sign when
uh a software that you love gets
acquired and you're upset like i
remember when substance got acquired and
i was legitimately upset
and that's you know because i'm assuming
okay well what's gonna happen to it now
you know yeah and that's the thing that
drew me back to i did android for a
little bit you know the dark ages of my
life and i came back in like a phone
yeah okay and i i came back to darius
yeah a lot of people disagree with me
but the reason i came back was just it
worked like it's seamless it's
effortless it's there when i need it
it's reliable like that's worth so much
that's true not every android phone or
not every android operating system on
every phone
is the same experience
yeah no android has a lot of jank and
that's why people depending on your
depending on your hardware and what
version you have like it can be janky
yeah and this was seven years ago too so
yeah yeah but you can still be jacked
fair enough
samsung hasn't figured out the samsung
galaxies are they're as good as the
iphones nice i think
yeah
yeah
point being though i just feel like yeah
the attention to
just working
that's so valuable just working you know
and elevating your craft
yeah right absolutely
so and we're not saying like that node
workflows are inherently superior to
like layer workflows and after effects
so just different workflows like it's
like trying to say like oh yeah
photoshop's better than dreamweaver it's
like those are two different programs
that do two different things
um
but
oh yeah there's other things that are
just like
yeah
i don't know
it's tough it's tough like what do you
guys how do you guys feel about the fact
that
what you need to do what you need to use
to work to create your what you create
is so dependent on other people making
that tool for you
yeah scary
like yeah i mean imagine if
all of a sudden like
houdini was just like hmm
no
no more we're gone
no more
yeah or like adobe acquired
them oh my gosh can you right they just
they just shut it down
like that
yeah right like
it could just happen and then you're
like yeah you know searching through the
depths of the internet to find an old
yeah you're so right and like you
dedicate like i'm i'm frustrated because
i i loved after effects and you know
yeah i got quite proficient at it to
where i could just zone out i could
watch a show and when i look back at my
screen the shot's done because i just
know where everything is
very comfortable and i liked that yeah
and i'm i'm frustrated because i
invested in them and i don't feel like
they invested back that's that i think
is the crux of it for me and so yeah so
i'm going to nuke and now it's almost
like you kind of have to start again the
fundamentals are there but yeah i don't
know where all these things are just yet
and it's like this didn't have to be
this way but here we are so i think
that's really well put you know like i
have a bit of an ulterior motive too
with seeing you guys
you know work on more nuke which is
you know we're switching over to resolve
for our editing pipeline here corridor
you know it's we use resolve for all the
vfxrs react with the quarter crew
episodes uh it's not used for yet for
crew cuts i believe
um
but the thing is you know resolve has
fusion built in which is like it's nuke
light right
but as you guys you know jordan in
particular like as you do more nodal
base compositing i'm hoping that like
sometimes you'll be like ah i don't need
to go out to nuke for this i can just
stay in resolve and use fusion and the
more that happens the more like we start
to understand that software package and
just have it be this ultimate like
thanos gauntlet of like gemstones yeah
and like you have nuke if you want it
but for everything else you're just
banging out right in resolve yeah so i
think so like even just like if it's
like okay we're going through we're
adding 100 muzzle flashes like we don't
need to be jumping into nuke it's like
yeah you can handle that in like fusion
real easy and it's all it's all node
based so it's the same kind of language
like i think the main difference is that
fusion the nodes like extend out to the
sides whereas nuke it's like straight up
and down and that's it you can you can
switch that by the way yeah and then so
then it's like yeah it's basically the
same thing yeah yeah as long as yeah as
long as the fundamentals are the same
because
like a new that was the
biggest learning curve i think was just
navigating the simple stuff like okay
how do you handle
uh roto masks in this oh okay well it
has to run through this merge set to
mask and okay so it's like a different
way of operating but once that clicked
it felt very comfortable yeah yeah and
now it's just you know learning
really for me the the biggest hole is
learning more about what happens between
the sensor and the action and that's
what fenner you know so much about where
you're like oh yeah this is how the
light is supposed to distort and this is
this is this and this is that and you
like add these layers on top of a render
and it just looks so good
and i'm like man what is that's the
secret that i want to unlock eventually
it's just how to think like that but
that you know can be done in fusion yeah
yeah that's that's software agnostic at
the end of the day that's which is
exciting yeah
exactly exactly so
yeah
yeah once you get past the bugs of after
effects and you move over into nuke the
true power is possible i haven't even
been focused on the true power just
trying to get project stuff like the
various levels of like wizardry like
once you get to a certain point it
doesn't matter if it's like necromagic
or like mana magic or like life magic or
nature magic it's just all magic and you
can handle it yeah
you might have to take a moment to like
learn the new runes so you can read them
or whatever but like after that's like i
get it and you know it's funny it's the
exact same in houdini as well yeah where
there are all these different branches
of simulation but the core information
is the exact same so once you understand
the fundamentals
now all of a sudden you can do all this
kind of arcane magic yeah it's pretty
special it's exciting
so yeah anywho
i i feel like we
have really went hard
um we've gotten our gripes out
um now for those who might be listening
who
you know what about caroline
guys
yes you know like what do you what do we
say to her is it her fault no no of
course no it's not caroline's fault and
adobe has a lot of great products by the
way like in particular we're ranting
about premiere in after effects
in particular
but yeah i mean
yeah what would you guys say what would
you guys say to caroline if you were
sitting next to us uh
i'd say first don't don't give us
just
hard stop on the marketing speech
yeah right don't give me any of your
marketing speak
yeah but like let let me hear from you
on the reel
because you know they give them
it's like at a company that size it's
like okay when you hear this this is the
package to answer that
we'd like you to say right yeah but
here's
the package to answer doesn't address
the true thing which is probably
hey sorry this is running on ancient
code
yeah maybe
but maybe if they announced like hey
ladies and gentlemen we're building a
new farmhouse
it's gonna be great
speaking openly about what the problems
are like that's
that's the thing that i really pride
ourselves on here is that because we
don't work for any other company we can
just talk openly about stuff like we
don't have politics to worry about in
the film industry like if when we see a
janky vfx shot we can say it's janky and
no that's so funny i was listening to an
old podcast where you were going on
about that and because yeah as the show
especially like a year into the show as
it started to get bigger and people
became more interested in it uh that's
one thing that we've had to deal with is
like we get all these great guests which
is amazing and wonderful
but most of the time uh they don't want
to even
critique in a constructive manner
other people's work
and there's a lot of reasons for why
that is um you know in particular i
think it's just sort of trying to have a
general respect for uh you know the
other professionals in their industry um
but
it's nice to be able to have the freedom
to just go
well yes and and also this didn't look
good let's talk about why that is yeah
it's a hard enough craft as it is like
and you know it's like
it's incredibly difficult and it's not
just
how good you are as an artist you could
be the best artist in the world but if
you get the worst raw footage in the
world
that's still gonna have a detrimental
effect on the outcome yeah and here we
can be like we can be open about like
yeah we didn't quite pull us off right a
mistake in this shot or whatever like
we don't have to worry about being
perfect and we can acknowledge our
mistakes if we don't have you know
millions and millions of dollars in egos
and politics on the line you know we can
just be like yeah whatever and then we
can speak that way about other work too
to an extent and obviously we're not
ever trying to be disrespectful about it
or just mean-spirited but it's nice to
be able to talk openly about things and
like
so it'd be nice if adobe could be like
yeah here's where these problems are
coming from and we're just going to tell
it to you straight
you know it's because of this
and this is what we are actually doing
to address it or this is not going to be
addressed for the next couple years or
whatever you know
but they can't they're not obviously
can't do that otherwise they would have
done i can't do that because their stock
price will tank yeah i was going to say
it's as soon as they acknowledge their
subscription numbers
yeah but i feel like if they
acknowledged it but at the same time
laid out like a plan to be like hey
we're doing like photoshop 2 and it's
like rebuilt after effects rebuilt
premiere rebuilt and they laid out like
a road map for that then
maybe they'd earn some sort of
trust back from all the people that
they've lost it from like a lot of us i
think they would i think they definitely
would like why not do that you know it
can you imagine if like ford still just
made model t's yeah
you know
the 2022 model t is something else let
me tell you why
you know
it's like it's okay they came up with
new models they came up with better
designs they
they built new cars
and yeah not all of them were winners
but still they're still here 120 140
years later or whatever it is
yeah
and uh yeah it's okay
yeah it's always interesting seeing like
or just being like what's going to be
the next hell like technology that's
going to take this out because
eventually like nothing lasts forever
eventually something will take that down
you know like what's gonna be the next
like compositing suite that takes down
nuke like maybe it's fusion maybe it's
like something completely new
like i mean you know in the industry for
a long time like softimage was huge
right and 3ds max was huge
and maya was huge and now it's like yeah
you know what we have like i mean you
know under gaming
i think the biggest one is like nuts
yeah and then like
yeah it's surprising to me how much of a
resistance there still is to programs
like blender because it's free because
it's free that i mean that's honestly
why i didn't pick it yeah when i was
younger it was like i mean granted it
was a much different
very very very different yeah but i
remember thinking even you know at 16 or
however old i was
you know oh that can't be that good like
what's the best one well i was i was
always i was 3ds max and then maya and i
was so fed up with maya
um it was probably like three years ago
and i just it was crashing on me over
and over again i was sick and tired of
v-ray
and then i downloaded blender because it
was the same thing it was maya would
crash all the time because it's become
such a bloated piece of software because
they're just like trying to shove in
like oh we're gonna throw xsi in there
and like they're trying to like
amalgamate it into this like
frankenstein program that just crashes
all the time and the same thing oh your
autosave is corrupt and i'm just like
what is going on
like and so that's that's when i
switched over to blender and i've been
very impressed with it because i you
know again i'd always heard like oh it's
not professional software i'm like yeah
you make it right like it works
yeah it's a hard thing to be intentional
about about growth yeah um
you know uh
like just just from our own perspective
of this tiny
because in the grand scheme of things
like quarter digital is this tiny little
you know boutique
thing yeah and and but even at that even
at the place that we're at
there's still all these temptations uh
with like oh there's this new
thing over here and there's this new
style of content over here and there's
this new output platform over here and
like oh if you just did this and a
little bit of that and then we did that
and if you did facebook what if you did
instagram what did you do yeah and nico
you've been to your credit you've been
very deliberate about
being like no let's let's focus on
what
is
what plays to our strengths let's focus
on distributing and creating for the for
the things that play to our strengths
because it's already competitive enough
just to get somebody to like see a video
that you've done right um and
uh
but i'm just saying like even at our
tiny baby level
uh
so i can't imagine what it's like when
you know you're you're this
35 year old or how how old is adobe
whether they're like 19
97 how old they not yeah i don't know
how old they are exactly no 82 so
they're 40 year they're a 40 year old
company
and like what kind of
opportunities you know if you can call
them that where things come along and
they go hey guys there's this little
software company over here we just
bought them we'd get all their
subscribers and all their
talent
and but is it is it but is it pulling
you away
from your core
function
and that's that's something that we
always talk about too like let's
let's not just
go oh let's just do this or do that
because we could grow or we could make
more money
you know it's it's
because that if you're just chasing
money like
yeah intentional growth is so important
i was having a conversation about this
last night with like in regards to vfx
studios and
there's so much work in the vfx industry
right now that every studio is like
rapidly expanding and they're just
throwing money at whoever they can hire
basically and it's like
so unsustainable because then you end up
with uh like a team of people that might
not be competent and able to complete
the work
up to the quality so then they're ended
up doing insane amounts of overtime and
then you're having to pay them that over
and it's like you end up
like because you just were trying to
grow you end up like spending more money
and like having less of a profit because
you tried to like just jump into that
growth rather than being like okay let's
be intentional about this let's turn
down a project let's like make sure
we're putting the right people in place
yeah it's like so important that's why
the pyramid's the best shape
build the base as you build the height
yep right build a base to support the
height and otherwise
you get five people to subscribe and
then
and then and then all the money goes
back to you man it's great it's science
wow that sounds like a great deal jake
tell me more
and that's the thing there's like
there's two ways you can approach to
like when you have more work than you
can do there's like two ways to approach
it one way is to grow and just take it
all on
and the other way is to say no to things
and there's a time for a and there's
time for b but i feel like more often
than not if people just pause and been
like
do you want to do that
no it's not about the money you have it
you can pick any job you're gonna be
working no matter what but do you want
to do that and it's like well if i think
about it that way
no it's like right and don't do it yeah
actually that was one thing that did
come up when i first started working
here was i was still getting you know
the freelance offers mm-hmm on the side
and now at first i was debating i was
like well my weekends are open like
maybe i'll go work the weekends you know
what i mean just go on set and do this
and i did that one time and very quickly
i felt very thin very spread very very
thin and i thought if i want to have a
sustainable and good time here
i need to protect the weekends
and that's kind of a parallel really is
you know keeping the base strong so that
you can you know grow at a good rate and
so i have this problem i have this
problem because i i'm constantly
one that abides by the philosophy of
you know we were talking about this in
another podcast but never never be
satisfied with like
the totality of where you're at always
appreciate it but but always be striving
to grow in another way and in another
method and learn something new and just
stay sharp and stay well-rounded and i
find myself constantly
going okay so i i incorporated this new
thing and you know in my skill sets or
in the things that i know or the things
that i'm good at and then once i am able
to find the balance of those things i
immediately go out and look for
something else
and then you get that feeling again
where you're spread too thin and you're
overwhelmed and you go oh i gotta cut
stuff out you know i gotta try i gotta
do something different
um
yeah it's it's interesting because i
personally in my own life i feel like
that sometimes where
if it hadn't been for that i guess
ambition of trying to learn and do new
things
i wouldn't be uh you know i guess i feel
like as well-rounded or you know as
fortunate as i am but
if if i would have just maybe if i would
have just stuck with one thing you know
maybe that would have
also had the same outcome
i don't know
i think it's nice to be well-rounded it
makes life a lot more interesting and
more exciting when you end up doing new
things but
you know we also have like that
philosophy here of like if you don't
live life at all you don't have anything
to make art about
right that's that's why we try not to
let people stay here too late that's how
we don't do all-nighters that's why we
try to go home on the weekends so we
have holidays off here and there it's
like yeah you got to live life you got
to like you know you got to be a person
with emotions and experiences and like
stories you're going to then come in and
like
put that on camera at all well yeah fun
story about the culture side of things
here at corridor for those who are
curious
uh when i first came here i was coming
off obviously working freelance and you
know i wouldn't turn off i'd just go and
go and go and go and burn out and then
take a break and then go go go and when
i first got here one of the first
projects we did
um we were like a tad behind i think on
the deadline we were aiming for and i
went up to niko at the end of one day i
don't know if you remember this but i
was like if you need me to stay i can
stay i can do this tonight like i can
get this done
and nico like he put his hand on my
shoulder and he's like it can be done
tomorrow go home
and i was like oh i like it
here that's very nice of you so yeah
that was pretty cool so yeah the balance
is it's important it's super important
yes it's super important it's it's the
whole thing in my opinion
yeah
so adobe if you're listening
please you know maybe
i know we're just little baby
cockroaches to you but
you know
maybe if you hear us but we live here
too
listen i'm just trying to make it easy
for them to feel good about hating this
podcast okay oh yeah yeah yeah there's
room in our hearts for
forgiveness yeah yeah and renewal it's
there the possibility's there you know
even though you stepped on our cousin
hey as far as i know adobe photoshop is
still cool yeah and mix the mode is
great make sure makes the most awesome
good like i
i could probably from this point
forwards never use premiere again i
think i've managed to cut it out of my
diet entirely
and uh i think i can live without it
completely yeah your content diet
yep
so i'm i'm i'm making that step adobe
and i'm i'm down to come back you know
i'm done to come back but
but you gotta earn it
you're in after effects free like that's
that's good
you're gonna have to come back with a
bouquet of flowers and a fifth of wine
yeah and uh really apologize the foundry
was already flirting with us in those
batman comments i don't know if you
really really yeah yeah yeah they're
like wow would you find out like the
person you're a fan of is a fan of you
see i wasn't sure that was actually the
foundry or just somebody that had the
name foundation oh it's actually the
face
hey the foundry if you're listening
if you if you give us licenses for all
our computers
i will stop we will stop using adobe in
the studio period we're going to make it
happen let's do it we're going to make
it happen and people are going to
struggle and they're going to hate it
but you know what
we will do it slide into our dms yeah
we'll do it 100 we'll go cold turkey
we'll still use photoshop sorry we still
use photoshop yeah griffin needs
photoshop asterisk photoshop's fine it's
great we're still going to use miximo
yeah i won't though i promise
what are you really sad though i don't
even know how to use it i won't use it
we'll probably have like two or three or
no like after effects licenses still
yeah
anyway yeah
yeah i hope anybody listening from the
actual software teams like you know
we've met people uh from all the
companies and they're wonderful people
and i hope i hope if you guys are
listening you know that really at the
end of the day we're just
we're just looking for the best product
we know you guys are working hard we
just we wish the priorities were a
little bit more focused not a little bit
let me rephrase that let me be honest i
wish the priority priorities were a lot
more focused on making premiere in
particular and adobe after effects
stable
modernized
rethought programs
that acknowledge what we do this in this
day and age with video editing and i
know there's parts of it that do but
it's built on that old farmhouse
that still has like cracked foundations
it's rv strapped to it it's an old it's
an old farmhouse and then they bought a
bunch of acreage and they put a chicken
producing manufacturing plant like on
the far acreage and what we're looking
for is like
home-grown you know we'll pay the
premium to get the good chickens you
know
we want you guys to make the good
chickens and the good cows and the good
pigs and the free range adobe
exactly we want the free range and and
we'll pay the premium for it if it's if
it's worth it because it'll it'll be
it'll taste delicious yeah definitely
well thanks ren for tweeting and
starting this whole yeah i think that's
the title of the pot i think the title
of this podcast is after effects needs
to be rewritten from the ground up or
i'm not using this effing program
yeah what do you have to say for
yourself
i wanted
i wanted ren to be in on this cast but
uh he's he's researching for
react
yeah it's such a funny tweet
look at some good stuff
mm-hmm
what are you looking at tomorrow well
i'm we're gonna finally look at that
clip from black widow uh that made the
rounds
not so good vfx oh yes i've seen this
and i'm looking forward to kind of
breaking down
why it looks the way it does and what's
the situation it was in and how you
could have how they could have possibly
approached it and perhaps why they
didn't yeah so yeah i like that in the
past you know you've acknowledged that a
lot of this jank so to speak can come
down to time yeah and simply resource
yeah you know it's like here's the
foreground character shot
with studio lighting here's the
background it's sun lit clouds yeah do
your best it's like all right i'll do my
best and then the the other thing i
really like going going into is like
so let's say you're given those same
exact elements what else could you try
what other things could you mess around
with to try to like improve upon it you
know it's a classic like oh you've done
lens flares but have you tried
chromatic hammer shake
camera shake yes i mean that's almost
what every single one of these boils
down to
we should make a plug-in that just it
does all of those things at the same
time the camera shake the motion blur
the chromatic aberration the dirty lens
lens yeah like the washer yeah yeah the
diffuse and just one slider and just it
turns all of those things out
simultaneously you're down it's like an
instagram filter
it's just blender like image blender
yeah yeah yeah it doesn't it has
literally no features you just import
the video file and then you just do the
slider and hit export
and yeah it just slowly degrades and
compacts all your footage together
the make real button yeah yeah it turns
out the solution is just like turn the
resolution down and recompress it five
times
just
send it through media encoders uh-oh oh
another adobe yeah it crashed
shoot man
something must be wrong export every
part of the timeline until you find the
part that's failing
you know how many times we've had to
just screen capture with shadow play
just the playback in premiere because it
won't export and don't crash
too many times it's funny yeah you don't
realize how many bad memories you have
until it gets brought up i have i have
so many stories
now i think about i have so many stories
i mean the part where it's like we
waited like four years for black magic
raw support and eventually nobody's just
like no you have to get a third party
because we don't want to help our
competition
it's like really adobe
yeah that actually reminds me when i was
using final cut 7 and i totally forgot
about this this era where it couldn't
handle certain
right remember that yeah
codex yeah and then premiere that's what
lured me over i was like i can just drag
it into the bin and it loads in yeah
everything at the time
and uh yeah that was one of the most
attractive features that was yeah that
was totally like mind-blowing
yeah man
we're all just processing just
emotionally exhausted over here
the war's over guys
it didn't end the way we wanted but it
it had an eventual outcome and i think
the outcome is uh we'll be using
premiere and after effects as little as
practicable and i you know i sympathize
for caroline i really do because
someone's gotta do that job right
someone's gotta step out in front of
those bullets
oh also like hey everybody listening did
you know that davinci resolve is free
yeah a little tidbit yellow tidbit
that's the one other thing like when i'm
sitting there like logging into like
premiere for like the fifth time today
because i jumped to my laptop for my pc
and she's like
uh and it's like premiere i'm just it's
free i can just open it at any computer
and i can just use it that's great yeah
if you think about it if you're just
starting out in visual effects
you have access to resolve which gives
you access to fusion blender and unreal
yeah you can force free and unreal yeah
blender and real raving resolve like
that's crazy all open not open source
but at least free yeah so crazy that is
nuts that is totally nuts
or fifty dollars a month
for adobe a program that will delete
your work
uh
crazy
crazy man
well
i hope i hope they're like encouraged by
this i hope this is motivating
i'm sure they're just like whatever yeah
yeah all right cool thanks for listening
to us about adobe everybody just a
reminder davinci resolve it's free you
should go check it out they have now
they don't have ai depth maps in them
which is pretty crazy
they have ai object masking and davinci
resolve now like in runway ml that's
awesome you need to roto-brush it you
just click on the person and then it
cuts them out you're like oh i'm done
let's oh yeah yeah i'm starting this
song in d minor
the saddest of all chords say d or b
d e minor d minor
it's an ode to dobie
d for depressed
[Music]
oh heavy heart
after effects needs to be rewritten from
the ground up
or i'll stop using this
effing program
after effects needs to be rewritten from
the ground up
or i'll stop
using this
effing program
oh
yeah do the refrain with freddie's tweet
that's what i'll start the next podcast
with technical debt technical
technical debt technical debt technical
debt